what is so insidious or what is so
harmful what is the long-term negative
impact of creating that culture of lying
within teams and within ourselves
well there's a there's this there's this
uh psychological uh um phenomenon i
guess called ethical fading
uh which can
grip an organization's culture
where
people within that culture become
capable of making highly highly
unethical decisions believing they were
well within their own ethical frameworks
right
so
extreme examples
are things like pharmaceutical companies
who have a patent on an essential drug
and in order to meet or beat some
financial projection they raise the
price of that essential drug 100 500
1000
1500
totally legal there's nothing illegal
about that
really unethical
right
and
in organizations that suffer ethical
fading it almost always if not always
starts from the top it's usually a
leadership problem
it comes from excessive amounts of
pressure to hit certain short-term goals
to the point where
doing it ethically becomes more and more
difficult
and so what creates ethical fading is a
series of things one of those things is
we we rationalize
right we look for ways to distance
ourselves from the impact of our
decisions we say things like it's what
you got to do to get ahead
it's what my boss wants
um everyone's doing it
it's the system i don't have a choice
right
um and there are ways we can
disassociate our responsibility right so
rationalizing is a big part of it
another part is the old slippery slope
you did it once you did it a little bit
it worked we raised the price 10 nobody
even noticed great do it again do 20
this time try 100
and it just keeps going and going and
going and going before you have
full-blown ethical fading
and um some of the things are excessive
use of euphemisms again we're using
language to disassociate ourselves from
the impact of our decisions so for
example you know um
we in the united states would never
torture but enhanced interrogation that
sounds very appealing
right or companies would never spy on
their customers but data mining yeah i
know we're really into that
right
we're just using different language to
to mask
the insidiousness of our real decisions
like everybody talks about managing
externalities
but we don't talk about the damage we're
doing to the people and cultures
environments of the places where our
offices and factories are located why
don't you have that conversation
and so when you have enough of those
things
ethical fading shows up where you now
have
real issues and in the extreme you have
massive scandals sometimes it leads to
illegal activity but usually it's just
unethical scandals
and when those things happen management
is dragged out and they talk to the
newspaper to the law and they always say
the same thing which is we broke no laws
everything we do is legal no we don't
have an issue with the law we have an
issue with your ethics
um but when you don't have when it's not
full-blown it just becomes an incredibly
uncomfortable and a horrible place to
work
that increases stress to the point where
you'll do damage to your own health and
you'll do damage to the way you treat
your family because when you're into
that kind of stress to violate your own
ethics
at work um you're gonna come home and
you're gonna take it out on your your
spouse and your kids you're gonna kick
the dog
um you're not gonna be motivated to do
much except sit and sit on the couch and
watch tv
you know
so it has it's had some pretty insidious
impact in the lives of human beings